Did you know that
here in the Pacific Ocean,
there's this huge
deposit of valuable metals?
Everyone agrees
that our future
is going to contain metals
like nickel,
cobalt,
copper
and manganese.
These metals are
key ingredients
to making batteries,
which we need
a lot of very soon
to get us away from
this.
Burning hydrocarbons
to move our bodies
and our goods
around the world.
One way to get all
these metals
is to send
giant robots
to the bottom
of the ocean floor
to vacuum up
all of these deposits
and then to send them up
to the ship on the surface.
But there's one big problem,
which is that
this patch of ocean isn't
owned by any country.
It's international waters.
So countries are going to
have to work together
and establish rules on
how to do this properly.
And at this point,
we don't know what
the environmental
implications are
of just digging up
all of these metals
from the bottom of the ocean.
This is just one of
the many difficult trade-offs
that the world is facing
right now
as we figure out
solutions to this
climate crisis.
If you want to better understand
global politics,
follow for more.